like you need to figure out what works
for you like we're we're very empathy
for all the speed or whatever we have a
lot of good things and empathy would be
one of them so what you know I think I
don't get burned out even though I go so
hard every day always because I just
know first of all doesn't happen that
often because I love it so much but I
know that if it's not clicking right
that I have my levels to escape whether
that's you know I think this is gonna
sound very weird you know the Jay Kings
help me a lot
I'm not kidding like I release a lot of
stress you know if I have to take a big
you know if on the weekend if I have to
completely shut down
also perspective like I think I'm really
blessed and like it's hard for me to
complain about work like in a world
where like every day cuz we're a big
company now I have emails of like my mom
has open-heart surgery my cousin died my
you know we had a miscarriage like in a
world where every single day now because
of how many people I'm connected to and
how many people work for me that I hear
something that's real every day it's
just hard for me to say like I [ __ ] up
this project or I lost this account or
I've got employees that are stressed
like these are real things but there's
still business and their champagne
problems compared to you know you know I
just kind of every day like if
everybody's healthy like I'm not joking
like my perspective is on point you know
like and that's where I would say to you
like use me use clawed use and use
whatever is right for you to like as
much as it might be like [ __ ] like I
don't want to be here to eleven o'clock
at night or this is too much pressure I
hate like these two people are [ __ ]
always conflict and it's like so
negatively
whatever whatever it may be find a way
to communicate it out to whomever you
know internally like you know dumping
everything on your partner or mom or dad
that's like always tough like and that's
what most people do it's my family
dynamics are interesting but please rest
assure that that's super interesting for
me to empower everybody here to have an
outlet in whatever way I can be
including like that's why we have
unlimited making
in time you know like getting ahead of
that and I think people put their own
pressure on it like used like everybody
so like we have such a great company and
so people have so much pride and like I
can't just do that we have these pride
like it's understanding you can and
understanding that the masses can
fulfill that it's just communicating and
that's what I do I communicate with
myself first and communicate with
whomever else for me it's a little bit
lonely cuz it's all on me kind of thing
you know like if everybody takes a day
off that's on me you know but um I think
that's how to be honest with you
perspective and understanding and
through that perspective understanding
that talking me right you know and so
like you know what I want to do in these
five minutes is like pound at home for
you if it for like if you community
there's nothing scary here like if
people are good at what they do
and they have the right intent they're
gonna win so
you